نعم مجددا نحن في نفس المنطقه التي نتواجد
فيها هنا في مدينه او في بلده نورتا
التابعه لولايه غازي عنتاب هذه البلده
التي تضررت بشكل كبير نتيجه الزلزال كما
تتابعين نحن الان اشرقت الشمس يعني كنا
نحاول ان نبحث عن احد
عن احد ما نجري معه مقابله لكن على ما
يبدو ان الجميع ما زال النيام
الوقت مبكر جدا في تركيا لكن بالعموم هذه
المنطقه تحولت وهذه الاراضي الزراعيه
تحولت بشكل كامل الى نقاط لتجمع او تجميع
المخيمات تقريبا
الكاميرا ترصد جانب
واحد من هذه
الخيام او هذه المخيمات لكن هناك على
الجانب الاخر من الطريق ايضا مخيمات اخرى
تنتشر وسط الاراضي الخاليه قرب مدينه او
بلده نورداغ هذه البلده تضررت بشكل كبير
وهي اكثر
بلدات التركيه او هنا في غازي عنتاب تضررا
اضافه الى مدينه اصلاحيه القريبه مصادر
تركيا تتحدث عن نيه الحكومه هدم المدينتين
بشكل كامل لان عفوا بسبب الدمار الكبير
الذي حل بهما طبعا نتحدث عن نوردا او حتى
اصلاحيه اكثر من نصف المباني نهارك
بالكامل احياء بالكامل انهارت لم يتبقى
منها اي شيء واينما باتت اقوى من الركام
ايضا قسم كبير من المباني التصدعت بشكل
كبير
وهي غير صالحه للسكن هزات ارتداديه ما
زالت
تشهدها هذه المدينه كما نشاهد يعني الان
الكهرباء اعيدت بشكل جزئي الى هذه المدينه
لان وحتى فقط للشوارع الرئيسيه لاناره
الشوارع الرئيسيه حتى الان شبكات الكهرباء
وشبكات المياه تعاني من اضرار كبيره لا
توجد كهرباء او
شبكات مياه
هنا محاولات حتى اقيمت في المناطق
التي نرى في محيط هذه الخيام نرى اجزاء من
حطام على ما يبدو
نعم هي اقيمت في مناطق نائيه فيها بعض
المنازل لكن حتى هذه المناطق النائيه كما
تشاهدين هدمت فيها المنازل وسط المدينه
غير ممكن يعني ركام في كل مكان لا يمكن
انشاء القيام لذلك تم انشاء الخيام في هذه
المنطقه نوعا ما بعيده عن مركز البلده لكن
الاحجار التي تحيط بهذه الخيانه نجد بعض
الاليات الرافعات هذا هو ركام
هو ركام لبعض المنازل التي كانت هنا كنت
تتحدث هذه المنطقه في جوار مركز المدينه
بعيده نوعا ما عن مركز البلده لكن هنا حتى
في الضواحي اي في محيط بلده نوردا كان
هناك منازل وتهدمت هذا طبعا يعني من شده
الزلزال رغم ان هذه المنازل ليست ابنيه
طوابق مرتفعه انما بناء مكون من طابقين
اثنين فقط لكن مع ذلك تهدم بشكل كبير او
دمر بالكامل هذا نتيجه شده يعني تحدثنا
باعتقال عدد من المقاولين الان لمخالفه
هذه الم
لا شك ان النور ده شهدت فيها مشاريع حديثه
طبعا الشريحه شاهدناها في الايام الماضيه
قد انهارت ابني حديثه لذلك عمليه اعتقال
مقاولين ما زالت مستمره لكن ايضا هنا من
ناحيه اخرى كنت تتحدث عن اسباب الدمار
الكبير اضافه طبعا الى موضوع اعتقال
المقاولين والشبهات بان المباني مخالفه
للمعايير الخاصه بالزلازل مدينه نورداغ
تعرضت في يوم الزلزال يوم الاثنين الى
اولا اضرار كبيره من الزلزال الاول الذي
ضربك كهرمان مرعش وكانت قوته 7.8 بعد ربع
ساعه من الزلزال الكبير تعرضت الى اقوى
هزه ارتداديه تشهدها البلاد حتى الان في
موجه الزلازل التي شهدناها وكانت شدتها
6.6 هذه الهزه الارتداديه اتت على ما تبقى
من المنازل التي كانت متصدعه اتت على قسم
كبير من المنازل اتيكان متصدعه ثم بعد ذلك
في ساعات حد الثاني ايضا في كهرمان مرعش
وكانت قوته 7.6 ايضا المدينه تاثرت بشكل
كبير وانهارت تقريبا معظم المباني التي
كانت متصدعه وبالتالي حتى المباني التي
كانت نجت من الهزه الارتداديه التي كان
مركزها
والزلزال الاول الكبير تصدى قسم كبير منها
وبالتالي المدينه اصبحت نستطيع ان نقول
انها منكوبه حتى المرافق العامه فيها
مهدمه حتى المساجد هنا مهدمه تقريبا او
متضرره بشكل كبير وغير صالحه للاستخدام
ابدا او
للعباده لذلك هذه المدينه كما ذكرت مصادر
تركيا تحدثت عن ان الحكومه التركيه تفكر
بشكل كبير
بهدم هذه المدينه ومن ثم اعاده بنائها من
جديد يدلل على ذلك القرارات التي اصدرتها
اداره الهجره للاجئين السوريين في مدينتي
اصلاحيه
النور ده بضروره مغادره هذه المنطقه لم
يتم التصريح عن السبب لكن بقيه اللاجئين
في الولايات العشر المنكوبه حتى في مركز
ولايه غازي عنتاب يمكن للاجئين العوده
اليه الى هذه المدن بعد
عوده الخدمات الطبيعيه اليها باستثناء
نورداغ واصلاحيه وهذا ايضا اشاره الى ان
هذه المدينه سيتم اخلائها هذه الخيم التي
نشاهدها هنا على الشاشه هي
طبعا غالبيه سكان نورداغ الذين بقوا هنا
ولم يغادروا البلد سيتم نقلهم فيما بعد
خلال ايام قليله او ربما اسابيع قليله الى
اماكن ايواء مؤقته يعني هذه القيم لا يمكن
ان تستمر الحياه فيها بشكل دائم لذلك
سيتم نقل متضرري الزلزال الى ولايات اخرى
في وسط الاناضول في شمال تركيا على البحر
الاسود في انقره اسطنبول وايضا في مناطق
ايضا مناطق الولايات على البحر المتوسط تم
تعطيل الجامعات حتى الصيف انتقل
وبدا من ذلك سيكون هناك عمليه التعليم عن
بعد لطلاب الجامعه لافساح المجال لافراق
كل السكن الجامعي في كل الجامعات التركيه
وبالتالي خلق اماكن ايواء مؤقته لحين
انتهاء عمليات اعاده الاعمار التي اكد
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان يوم امس
بان حكومته ستبدا ببناء 30 الف وحده سكنيه
في مطلع مارس القادم